all we've really had from the government
though is the announcement of a policy
that doesn't work then the
reannouncement of the same policy
essentially and it often feels I think
like Groundhog Day and uh meanwhile
that's costing a fortune for the
taxpayer there's there's this growing
sense of frustration I mean I'm at
Hinckley Point C here today fantastic
project it's behind schedule and there's
a frustration here that there's no real
plan whether it's small boats or nuclear
from the government and that dither and
delay is holding our country back so
there's a pattern of behavior here and
it's it's no plan for this government a
dithering delay and that is holding us
back one thing the government has done
is made a deal for instance with Albania
that they can send back people who are
not entitled to come here hundreds have
gone what do you see about that that's a
progress isn't it look a deal with
Albania is a course progress but we need
many more returns agreements because at
the moment the government's baked in a
problem which is because they haven't
got returns agreements with other
countries because they're not tackling
this
Upstream with cross-border criminal
activity being absolutely dealt with and
because they're not processing the
claims quickly enough they're building
an ever-growing problem and there's this
General sense now I think that 13 years
of holding our country back different
delay and not delivering you know when
we've got so much to offer in this
country